great welcome welcome everyone please
take your seats and we'll we'll get
started welcome also to those of you who
may be joining us by webcast it's great
to have you
with us here virtually uh i'm rebecca
finley and i represent one half of the
partnership
that's bringing today's event to you i'm
from cfar or the canadian institute for
advanced research
and our partner of course is
the united way toronto and york region
micheline la flesche the director of
research public policy and evaluation
and i have been talking
at least for a year it maybe feels even
a little longer than that about uh about
working together and it's really just so
great really great that that today has
come has come together
it was
a few months ago indeed that michelin
and ruth crammond and amy cook
with us at cfar and i sat down and we
started to talk about what we could do
together and i think we set ourselves a
fairly
challenging and ambitious goal for today
and under the broad title of researching
with community our hope was to try to
bring two groups of leaders together
those in the social policy and health
settings together with those more in the
research world to deepen our collective
knowledge about the research process in
social and health settings and to
provide insights into the opportunities
for building stronger collaborations
between research and practice and the
work that we do
we all know intuitively that by working
more closely together we can create
innovative new programs and policies and
at the same time high impact knowledge
but the question that we often get asked
is how do i get started
and where do we go from here so
thankfully our four excellent speakers
today are going to be tackling this
question for us and they're going to
speak to it from very different
experiences and perspectives and really
try to engender a very honest
conversation about the opportunities and
the challenges they're in
but as you all know a conversation
requires much more than that it requires
all of you and there's a lot of
intelligence in this room and we're
really looking forward to you sharing
your own perspectives uh on this
question
both within this large group setting and
of course later within the breakout
sessions
it's also worth noting up front that
we're going to be creating a written
report to try to capture the knowledge
that comes out of today that resource
will be provided back to you and we hope
shared more broadly if it's useful both
within your networks and also uh through
ours
and then one of the last questions we'll
be asking today is sort of where can
this conversation go next what are some
more uh areas or questions that we would
like to explore together so today at
seafar this is a little bit about a
national dialogue series that we've been
putting together called change makers
we've held events in edmonton and
vancouver and are looking forward to
holding some more events in montreal and
calgary
so uh if you've seen the change blockers
but changemakers website
keep in touch with us there are
resources there both for from today's
event as well as from past events
and if you're uh can continue to be part
of us both virtually and in person that
would be very uh very exciting
cfar is an advanced research institute
um we've been committed to creating
knowledge that drives change for many
years we're probably most well known
within the social community and the
health setting community for the work
that we did with the social determinants
of health many people will know the book
uh what makes some people healthy and
others not that was the the work in the
early 90s that really laid out this
notion of income and how income drives
long-term health
for individuals and communities
and that work has continued to be
important to the work that cfar does
today we have a program called
successful societies which is now
looking at inequalities within the
cultural and social institutions that we
have in our communities and we have
another program child and brain
development which is looking at how
early adversity gets literally embedded
under our skin in our children's and
throughout our lifetime and of course
our two cfar fellows who are with us
today are in our group very long name
social interactions identity and
well-being and they are looking at how
social context and identity drives
well-being over the long term
so i'm going to turn things over to
michelin very shortly but before i do
i'd like to thank cfar's many supporters
including the governments of canada
british columbia alberta ontario and
quebec are canadian and international
partners as well as many individuals
foundations and corporations and i'd
particularly like to thank the rbc
foundation they have been with us right
from the very beginning and they are a
founding partner of this
dialogue work that we're doing called
ideas exchange so i'm going to welcome
michelin it's been a pleasure
working with the united way uh i have
the luxury of being able to go to many
of your reports and presentations in
terms of the work that you're doing
around research
you're a great partner and
really admire the work that you're doing
so
thanks
so i won't keep you too long i just
wanted to say a few uh words of uh
introduction as well
i don't have the pleasure of taking off
my spectacles the way rebecca did how
did what what how did that work
very big font
a minor mine is true but
i still can't see it quite
so uh we're happy to be here united way
is happy to be here today i'm happy to
be here today
um i'm happy to be here today because
i've been working on the charitable side
of research and policy work on the
charity side of research and policy work
for more than 20 years and that was
preceded by a short little foray into
the academic world as well as a lecturer
as a postgraduate student as a
researcher at various institutions in
canada and in germany
um but it wasn't very long before i
decided that really wasn't the right
world for me and i found my way into
luckily
something that crossed over it was a
charity it was supporting the charity
sector it was about advocacy and using
research to inform policy
and it was a nice little space somewhere
in between i thought it was the nexus of
both research and policy but of academia
and of community as well so i had the
privilege of being with an organization
in the uk called the running me trust
for more than 13 years and i'm being the
ceo there for more than nine of those
years as well
and it was also a privilege to come back
to canada uh after many years away to
join the united way and we sit in that
nexus of research and policy as well
where research is there for a purpose
it's there for us to inform the work
that we're doing and it's there for us
to inform our advocacy agendas and to
try to influence policy with so we take
a very active approach to our research
it's not all community-based sometimes
it is sometimes it isn't sometimes it's
in partnership with academia sometimes
it isn't but it all has the purpose of
trying to inform what we're doing
actively
and so i've been in lots of in both
roles at runnymede and at united way
really great partnerships with academia
i've been part of esrc projects economic
social research council projects there
and sshrc council projects here
and had a really great time doing it but
that experience i know is not the same
for everyone not for everyone on the
academic side of that partnership and
not for everyone on the community side
of that partnership
and some of that is about uh i guess a
mutual understanding sometimes the
relationship feels uneven and that the
power in those relationships isn't
distributed equally and sometimes it's
just about not knowing how to work
together and how to understand each
other's place in what we need from
research and how research can
effectively inform our work and make us
work well together
and so what we wanted to do today was
begin to stimulate some good connections
in the toronto region with our partners
at cfar try to have this conversation
and think about how we can build mutual
understanding for the purposes of coming
to work together
so we know this value of the research
for us at united way and we know that
cfar understands the value as well
rebecca was talking about the work that
they've been doing that's relevant to
the work that we do in the community
it's relevant because it informs our
program design it's relevant because it
informs our program evaluations uh and
it also then informs our advocacy
platforms
and we know that many of our partners
are working really effectively using
research doing community-based research
themselves having really great
relationships working with academia and
we want to be able to share that
experience to talk about some of the
challenges on how we get there and to
think about how we can stimulate more of
that in our community here in the
toronto area
so we hope coming out of today
will be
between us united way and between cfar
that we promote more successful
collaborations we create some new
connections and that we find ways to all
continue to work together and so i want
to thank all of you for joining us today
to get this conversation started and we
look forward to having that
and so uh just to get us started then i
want to where's robin oh you're
see i can see here but not there
i want to introduce our moderator for
the day and that's robin corey robin is
an advisor to not-for-profit
organizations and foundations and
focuses on how to achieve achieve
greater strategic clarity
she's the founder of an organization
called colbeck strategic advisors and
it's a firm focused on supporting sector
leaders to make more informed strategic
decisions to increase their social
impact and i think she's had the
pleasure of working with many of us in
the room today asset united way i
believe you worked with west
neighborhood house as well and of course
with cfar so she comes with a a lot of
nice understanding of the different
spaces that we all work in so welcome
robin
thank you thank you michelin um
really delighted to be here um and as
michelin said i i um micheline said i i
um
have
personal ties to some of the
organizations here but a real um
personal connection to a lot of what
we're going to be talking about today
having seen firsthand through some of my
work with cfar and through some of the
the organizations that i've worked with
really the importance of this type of
collaboration and these types of of
synergies and i'm i'm really um pleased
to see um what i think is is really this
this bold session um and this important
opportunity to bring people together for
discussion um so with that spirit the
hope really today is for this to be
about idea generation bridging and
candor so i'll do my best to kind of
push
participation encourage participation i
won't cold call but i will kind of walk
around with the mic as we move into the
discussion portion so that we can hear
really from as many of you as possible
um
and so what we're going to do just in
terms of format is i'm going to briefly
introduce our four presenters you're
going to hear 15 minutes from each of
them we're going to have a few minutes
for questions in between but then
largely at the tail end of those four
presentations we're going to have some
discussion as a larger group as rebecca
said we're going to move into smaller
group discussions and then wrap up with
with a discussion altogether
really pulling out some of the key
themes that were generated from your
groups so without further ado i'm going
to start with maureen fair who i have
had the pleasure of working with um
in in her capacity as the executive
director of west neighborhood house
which is um some of you know formerly
saint christopher house it's a
multi-service neighborhood center
serving the west end of toronto and
maureen has had deep experience in
community development public policy
development and advocacy work through
many years over many years both in her
capacity at west and and otherwise and
is focused on issues of income security
income inequality
and neighborhood change
axel janser is the executive director of
access alliance multicultural health and
community services
she has led access alliance in really
enhancing
the services for immigrants and refugees
developing
a community-based research agenda which
you're going to get the chance to hear
more about and advocating for improved
access to those determinants of health
for individuals facing discrimination
and marginalization
um our two researchers here today both
c4 fellows both part of the the social
interactions identity and well-being
program which which rebecca mentioned
first kim mathison who you're going to
hear from first is a social and health
psychologist
and a member of the cfair advisory board
her work concerns the impact
of prejudice and discrimination on the
physical and mental health of members of
marginalized social groups
including first nations people which
you're going to hear more about some of
her work there she is a professor in the
department of health sciences
at carleton university and she's the
director of a center a carleton
university research center um called the
canadian
health adaptations innovations
immobilization center i think you're
going to really enjoy hearing from kim
as you will from phil who is an
associate director and senior fellow in
also in in the same cfar program
he is a professor of economics
at the university of toronto and his
research which i find fascinating
focuses on particular factors in early
stages of a person's development that
contribute to
long-run well-being and social economic
success and has quite a bit of
experience researching texting and the
power of texting um am i right is that
correct yes you're going to hear about
today a little bit too so without
further ado i'm going to call up kim
to kick us off
there make sure everything doesn't fall
off of here
as robin said i am a trained and have
been operating for about the last 25
years as a social psychologist an
experimental social psychologist and
it's been only in the last couple of
years that i have moved much more to
community-based research in order to be
able to
move the research to having an impact so
what i'm talking to you about is are
some of the lessons that i've learned in
part in hopes that you understand when
you reach into academia to try and take
advantage of the rich expertise that
exists there there is a patience
required as we go each of us goes
through this kind of a learning process
so i i do do research on discrimination
and its impact on marginalized groups
including
the well-being of members of
marginalized groups and the collective
resilience in terms of overcoming some
of the negative effects of
discrimination
in the past 10 years we moved to looking
at the effects of the indian residential
schools on the offspring of survivors
primarily through the use of national
surveys
that research provided us with a large
quantitative database that allowed us to
understand some of the mechanisms that
were associated with the greater
depressive symptoms anxiety trauma
symptoms of offspring of of both of um
survivors both the parents and
grandparents
who had encountered or experienced the
indian residential schools
it also allowed us to understand some of
the mechanisms how early life
experiences stress proliferation as
adults how identity disruption all
contributed to some of the
symptomatology and to start looking for
resilience factors
in this area having quantitative data
was was actually extremely important and
our work started to come to the
attention of for example the aboriginal
healing foundation which has since been
closed
but they became very supportive of our
work and brought us in to conduct a
number of other studies
including a study on the
student-to-student abuse that had
occurred in the indian residential
schools and what the implications of
that were for
continued lateral violence within some
of these communities
not surprisingly this was an extremely
sensitive issue for many aboriginal
communities
and their survivors and so when the book
was launched we held a blessing ceremony
in sue look at at the site of the indian
residential school at pelican falls
in order to be able to to launch this
with sensitivity and with an honoring of
the survivors and this was the beginning
of our work in the community of sioux
lookout
one of the members of the advisory board
of the healing foundation was garnet and
is garnet anjakaneb
and he
encouraged us following this ceremony to
take the work that we had been doing to
try to make a difference to make lives
better for the survivors of the indian
residential schools he has been a strong
advocate for the survivors and certainly
someone who has been pushing very
strongly for this to be part of the
canadian dialogue and part of the
canadian psyche
he has been our champion he is a he is a
residence of the sioux lookout area and
he is
a member of the laxul first nation he
has been incredibly supportive of us and
as we start to try to build
relationships in the area
and to help us not to step in onto too
many landmines
that champion within the community i
think is central to our ability to work
with the community
but it wasn't just a champion that
launched us into working with this in
this area and to moving towards a
community-based
approach
around the same time so last summer in
june and seafarer was part of supporting
this we held a nation a conference where
we brought people from across canada to
talk about aboriginal identity and
health these included practitioners
researchers students academics
and and
this provided us it wasn't the first
time people had talked about aboriginal
health of course and many of the members
of the audience and the speakers knew
each other but for us it provided us
with the relationship with that
community of practice that also meant
that we were able to rely on a
foundation of support as we moved
forward
our keynote speaker was james bartleman
who was the lieutenant governor of
ontario
and if any of you have ever heard him
speak about the suicides in first
nations communities in northern ontario
and the importance of education and the
call the plea for something to be done
about this issue then i don't think any
of you could have left the room with a
dry eye and not felt motivated to do
something
and finally around the same time again
so this was
a number of factors transpired to move
us very quickly into working with
community the community there were
funding calls that made it possible for
us to potentially get the funding to do
this work
community-based research as many of you
will know should not start with people
trying to get funding and i think many
of you have probably experienced
academics calling you up and saying
could we include your name on our
funding application because then it will
be successful and then you never hear
from them again and we were very aware
that this happens at the same time these
funding opportunities provide a basis
for focusing a relationship that that
people can figure out where we're trying
to get to and build a vision
and it also creates some sense that
there is a possibility of actually
implement implementing something if the
funding comes through
once you've started that relationship
building however there's no turning back
and we are still looking at many funding
opportunities even though the first one
that we worked on with this community
wasn't successful we have so many others
out there now that that you can't just
drop the community and say oh sorry
didn't work see you later
so
what is the project that we've been
working on
i'm going too fast for myself here i
know i have 15 minutes
we're working with the the region of sue
lookout the sioux lookout health we're
our primary partner the sioux lookout
first nations health authority catchment
region
and our focus is on youth suicide but
not directly and not from a clinical
interventionist perspective
the suicide rates in this region are 50
times five zero times higher than the
general population in canada one
community in particular picancicum has
among the highest rates in the world of
suicide
it is
it is what some would call a crisis
within the region
we're working together with community
organizations in the region to explore
strategies for building youth resilience
and creating community conditions to
foster a good life for the youth our
goal is to take a holistic perspective
to intervention that's multidisciplinary
multi-sector and community-led and
recognizes that this issue occurs within
a context
all of the communities in this region
have been affected by the indian
residential schools they are all
contending with issues of collective and
historical trauma
of continued systemic discrimination
associated with the legacy and continued
implementation of the indian act that's
resulted in
in poverty in adequate community
infrastructure
health inequities disadvantages in
education over-representation of the
children in the child welfare system and
over-representation of youth in the
justice system
there are many organizations working in
the region we're not the first
but the problems continue to exist
and not because people aren't
necessarily doing the right thing but
because there is very little
coordination across a region of
primarily flying
excuse me communities
funding runs out there are
jurisdictional issues that occur there
are equities across bands and banned
councils
and there is sometimes a lack of
evidence backing some of the programs
that are being implemented within the
communities
so we've been working in this region for
now and building the partnership for
almost two years
we have an idea based in evidence of the
kind of project that would actually
maybe make a difference so we walk in
and we had an idea based on the research
that a number of our partners who are
contributing to this we have a fairly
large team of about 30 researchers and
practitioners working with us from
various
organizations across canada now
and we thought okay one of the the areas
that we that many of our researchers
have found has been very effective and
particularly working with youth is to do
digital storytelling digital
storytelling allows them to get engaged
in a medium that they're very
comfortable with it allows them to get a
better understanding of their roots and
where their culture has come from and
and to understand their traditions it
can be used to connect them with elders
and adults within the community and to
connect them with each other and to
think about and envision a future for
themselves
we thought this was a great idea we
talked to youth about it they love the
idea many of the community organizations
also really like it but it's an idea
that has to wait for funding because we
don't have the equipment and we don't
have the resources to actually implement
it does that mean we have to wait until
we actually get funding that's not a
great idea to walk away from the
community because then you lose a lot of
the momentum and the credibility with
the community about your seriousness
so sometimes you just look at what's
already
been happening and
one of our experiences was to talk to
one of the deputy grand chiefs
of the region who basically when we
walked in to talk to him said we don't
need you we're already doing many things
and we don't need someone from ottawa
some white woman from ottawa coming up
and telling us how to be indian
and then he talked to me all about a
project that he has been championing
within the region called embrace life
i hadn't encountered brace life embrace
life before they had an event in
february of this year and so i and a
couple of my colleagues decided to fly
up to thunder bay to join the embrace la
life event
i have never before been to a
fundamentalist revivalist meeting which
is exactly what this was it was intended
to bring families together with
with with the lord to become stronger
and to work through the grieving process
associated with the losses that they'd
encountered it was complete with gospel
singers brought up from the thousand and
u.s
it was it was insightful it was a
learning experience as a researcher when
we're not there to judge
it wasn't necessarily something that we
could relate to but our job there was to
learn to understand a whole segment of
the community up there
christianity is a huge part of the
communities in in northwestern ontario
and to begin to figure out how we could
actually work within that context
there are other projects though that we
could actually jump into so one of the
public schools what has launched is in
the process actually of launching a
hockey academy hockey is also big up
there
the school had already put in a foreign
application for accreditation with
hockey canada they have equipment that's
been donated to them from jumpstart and
our role is to work with that school to
actually evaluate the potential impacts
of this program on the well-being of the
children so we have a role to play there
jumping on an initiative that was
already started by the community
so basically one of our first learning
lessons was that you don't walk in with
a project pre-defined that there is a
need to be flexible sometimes to stand
back and just watch sometimes to jump in
where they you might have something to
contribute to an ongoing initiative but
sometimes to also bring in expertise
that might not already exist there
and and apply that in conjunction with
the other kinds of events that are
ongoing
okay so we have to be flexible in the
nature of the project we also have to be
flexible
in terms of understanding who is the
community
so the tri-council chapter 9 actually
refers to
working with aboriginal communities and
we're supposed to consult and work with
the community to define the directions
for it what does this mean
we know that there is a very strong
christian element within almost every
single community in the region and that
stands beside a very strong traditional
element and some of these communities
even the elders are separated you have
the elders who are christian living in
one area of the community and the elders
who are traditional living in another
area of the community
sometimes they work well together and
sometimes it's extremely divided
you can't just look at the symbols that
would tell you because the one community
where 100 of the community speaks is the
native language is actually one of the
most christian communities in the region
yes you have to work with the the chiefs
and band councils you can't work with
the community without the permission of
the chief and ban councils but how
representative are they of the community
how representative are they of the
marginalized elements of the community
some of the people who are experienced
homelessness violence within the home
they've experienced child abuse are they
actually being represented by the chiefs
and how do you actually access them to
talk about these issues within community
the children have a voice we're looking
at youth resilience we have to talk with
the children it's not always compatible
with the views of the elders
the communities have very different
issues some of them in this region are
part of the ring of fire and they're
very concerned about the economic
development some are dealing with water
boil advisories for the last 10 years
some of them are living in very crowded
conditions who is the community
we have expectations of engagement so we
put together a whole group of
organizations that would work with us
and we start implementing oops one of
them has moved to another project
another one has moved to another
organization altogether one of them lost
his job and so is still working with us
but the organization's not been there
anymore oh but we do bring on others
that this is a team sport so you have to
keep bringing on organizations to work
with you
then we had a whole organization leave
us because their funding ran out and so
they couldn't put us as their priority
there was a
an election so our chiefs we had to
start again in terms of our relationship
building there you get the idea
some organizations are more stable and
they become central to the partnership
they become central sometimes because
they they are totally aligned with the
values that you represent
okay so many organizations are resource
strapped they're looking for the mule
power that we can provide often with our
grant funding we download a lot of work
onto community organizations we're
full-time researchers community
organizations are not and i'm sure you
understand that we often leave you with
our students to be able to fill in that
that working work power but students are
also work somebody has to oversee them
somebody has to make sure they're busy
all day somebody's supervising finding
them with a desk to work at a computer
to work at making sure that they don't
go out and make mistakes with very
vulnerable populations so they are there
are excellent experiences you can have
with students but they are not the
answer
i'm going to just quickly say that there
are issues around data who does it
belong to
whoops i'll go back one second um when
you get stories from community members
is it their story or the community story
the first nations are overseen by ocap
which i don't think every community has
that helps us helps guide us through
that there are issues around
accessibility of data and there are
issues around how the data is used often
community organizations are looking for
the data for advocacy
as researchers we often are motivated by
that need for advocacy but have to
remember what our contribution is is the
evidence that forms the basis of the
advocacy we are not the advocates and
that compromises the data when we start
seeing ourselves as the advocates
why do we do it we do it not for a lot
of bad reasons we do it primarily
because
we are interested in becoming part of a
process of working with communities
we're not trying to test our own ideas
and to publish necessarily what we're
trying to do is be part of a system that
can make a difference
that we can actually in our hearts and
souls find ways of taking what we know
as experts in our fields and making a
difference in the communities so thank
you
i gotta leave this and not walk off with
it thank you kimberly um i really as i'm
sure
people in the room are incredibly struck
and i was when we chatted in advance of
this by the thoughtfulness of the
approach clearly your commitment to the
youth and the communities but also the
the adaptability and in how you who have
gone about doing your work so um i think
those are themes that all i'll that'll
hear again and thank you for that um
so um
axel's gonna come up um
i think what we'll do is let's let's
have axel present and then pause for a
minute we can take questions on a couple
unless there's any any immediate
questions we'll have time at the end but
but i did promise we'd have time in
between um so actually if there's
questions we may just pause for a second
yeah go ahead let's take a minute or two
and if you've got um a question for kim
let's start with one or two now and come
back to more um i don't know if this is
on you know i think
acoustics are super yeah we're just a
digital audience
um
what do you say is this on or do i need
to do something
okay go ahead and talk and hopefully
it'll come on as you talk thank you
thank you very much
i don't think it's on kimberly for your
incredible presentation at the
powerpoint was just beautiful the images
were really compelling one thing i'm
grappling with is social innovation i
don't see social innovation anywhere
except on the hashtag of this event
and that term social innovation i know
changemakers you have a great definition
i don't have it at hand
do you see yourself as a social
innovator
i think that if you don't walk into
these communities thinking in terms of
social innovation that you're making a
big mistake that's when we start walking
in with preconceived ideas of exactly
what has to happen
and even if we have those preconceived
ideas they have to be adapted it may not
be transformational innovation it's much
more likely to be incremental innovation
but at the same time what you're taking
are programs um ideas an evidence base
and you're you have to transform it to
meet the needs of particular communities
we had no idea that we were walking into
a highly christianized environment what
does that do in terms of the ideas okay
we're going to bring you know drumming
and smudging and all forget it you know
you have to really think differently so
i i don't think we could walk into this
community without being
having a social innovation mindset
okay
yeah was there another question let's
take one more and then we'll uh
as a researcher who was just up in the
region and who does work in the region
i guess i i do have a couple questions
so i would like to talk to you later but
the question i would ask now is
i was just with some of the youth up in
dryden and
you know one of the things that they
talked about was when a person of
authority comes
into our community or comes into our
schools
it's triggering
it triggers
intergenerational trauma
of residential schools
it triggers family conflict
that comes from
people like teachers or principals or
police anybody in that position of
authority who's an adult
so how do you as a researcher going up
into these regions
who does not have a relationship
with those urban
communities or those
uh reserve communities how do you ensure
that you're not
just by being present there
triggering those individuals and those
community members okay
you're absolutely right i think in some
respects the whole education system has
this as a challenge that it is a trigger
for for many of the communities and
there's a huge mistrust of the education
system
there's a couple of ways in which we're
we're dealing with this one as our
primary
relationship with communities is through
the health sector not through the
educational sector because the health
sector has a much more
credible and positive relationship with
the communities
the other thing is that we would not
walk i would not walk into a community
school myself and start trying to talk
to the youth when we're talking with the
youth it has been
through the teachers and engaging them
to so with the hockey school it's not me
going in there these are the coaches the
teachers the parents the volunteers and
we're working with them
we have had dialogue circles with youth
it is not usually me that goes it's with
a again a trusted individual in the
community the person who's running the
youth programs
and my colleagues i'm i'm the white
woman
my colleagues are first nations and
they're the ones who are often going in
and working with youth and they're
trying to put things not in terms of
of
telling them what to do but exploring
within their own frameworks so telling
stories telling talking about
photographs talking about their own
experience
but is it is it is the the young first
nations members of our team who are
currently working directly with youth
oh hang on i can do this
okay great i think i'm just going to put
that
here put that there okay
so thank you very much for inviting me
to present and
access alliance i guess is a
a little bit of a different organization
let me explain we're a community health
center we're focused on working with
most vulnerable populations in toronto
our historical focus has been immigrant
refugee health but this has evolved over
the years in large part due to our
engagement
in community-based
research and so our understanding
as an organization is that
the impact of systemic barriers which we
do address is multi-generational and
impact so we do have to look at
uh generations uh in communities
so moving away from that immigrant and
newcomer
definition
and also our understanding of the impact
of the racialization of poverty so as a
community health center we made a
decision um
many many years ago
to
develop a community-based research
program so uh
you know
in um
consultation with funders and you know
with the support of our boards of
directors and you know with a little bit
of magic have
developed this capacity
this is our vision as you can see
we are systems change focused
uh again as i said the systemic barriers
individual services and community level
services is
very important but we have to look at
changing that system
so
as a community health center
we are uh committed to evidence-informed
decision-making and practice so this
suggests that we're guided by
the best research and information
available and again as an organization
many years ago when we started thinking
about this in a you know a drill down
way
uh that's when we started encountering
that's when we started developing our
approach to community-based research and
our commitment to
co-creation
of knowledge with communities
because from our perspective from the
perspective of our vision and mission
evidence is meaningless if it is not
linked to
systemic change so commitment to
systemic change so that's our
organization we have a research
department embedded in our
in our community health center
i'm not the researcher i'm the executive
director so i'm part of development of
the strategic
direction but we do have a senior
researcher
on staff who you know was an academic
and
came over to the other side
so
so i'm going to talk about some of our
experiences and and
things that we've learned
um
so most of them are self-evident i like
some of i think diane we asked
united way got feedback from
participants what were they what would
they like to think about diane talked
about you know we state the obvious and
i thought yeah that's so self-evident we
do state the obvious and
so what um
uh research is has no valuable if it's
not actual from our perspective
while we have
excellent experience working with
amazing academic partners many many many
researchers have very little interest
with the uptake of their research
and so this is this is often linked to
how then research
is carried out you know the kind of
institutional structure and framework
drives how the research is carried out
evidence and our experience is that
evidence is valued so unequally and
hierarchically
you know randomized control trial
studies and systematic uh reviews are on
top and qualitative and community or
grey literature on the bottom and we do
need to undo this hierarchical view
each type of research method and
evidence has its own unique value only
captures a piece of the story and it's
only in combination that um that they
can give us a more complete picture of
our very complex and messy
um
reality um
so i i have to i told you gender i would
name him because um he helps me do all
my thinking but i i sent him a question
by text about something and he sent me
back this answer
well it wasn't an answer it was just a
thought so and it's completely on point
so i want to read it
um this is yogendra shakkar our senior
research scientist undoing hierarchy is
a two-way process researchers who do
large-scale studies need to come to
terms with the fact that it is
logistically impossible for them to
reach and include marginalized
vulnerable groups in their studies which
is one of my points here there is a
persistent problem of
underrepresentation and undercount of
marginalized groups in large scale or
randomized control studies including
incenses and studies wanting to measure
inequities so they need to reach out and
consider community gray evidence more
seriously
not just in namesake community level
investigations including needs
assessments and program evaluation need
to pay closer attention to method
methodological rigor so we have our
piece to work
our piece of work to do on the community
side as well you know at lea he says at
least write down their methodology in
their report who they talk to why them
what they asked etc so
um
you know the absence of the most
vulnerable people from study cohorts is
very very problematic and we
consistently flag this so you're right i
mean we've we get called so often from
partners wanting to do studies and our
first question is are you talking to
anybody who doesn't speak english are
you going to be giving snacks at your
focus groups will you be giving ttc
tokens like how do you expect you know
and that's that's very basic um
and you know aren't even
really the most uh
impactful
uh access strategies however i do want
to say because it's important for me at
this stage in my career to
acknowledge that there's been massive
change and there is lots of hopeful
things going on in health in terms of
uh
yes the social determinants of health
actually do have something to do with
health so i love this infographic by the
canadian medical association where they
clearly clearly are
you know acknowledging what certainly
all of us working in
uh community have always always known
that if you're not talking about social
terms of health
then don't bother
um
so
so but so this is very positive and and
you know as i said we have had very
positive experience uh for the most part
with
researchers this is some of our
from academic researchers this is some
of our learning um
so our approach is community-based
participatory action research we work in
communities that have experience that we
have experience with so we don't go into
communities where we're not already
working in a service delivery capacity
or in a community engagement capacity we
recruit train and pay peer researchers
to participate in all our projects this
includes development of questions data
collection coding and identifying
emerging themes co-writing
and development of dissemination
vehicles and participation in knowledge
translation it's extraordinarily messy i
think somebody already said messi
takes a long long long time
it's very very expensive although we
managed to do it on a shoestring because
we're totally underfunded and unfunded
to do this kind of work especially the
participatory action base a piece of it
perfect evidence is not a and perfect
evidence is not a reality for us we
identify themes and we start moving
forward
with the transformative aspect of using
this knowledge because we are living in
these communities and and we see the
compelling need for
uh change and and we are working with
communities and it's transformative for
them too so they also want to
move you can't control
you can't control that nor would we
expect to it's interesting because this
process
you talked about data
we have had challenges around ownership
of data
understanding around ownership of data
in particular we've had experiences
where our academic partners have not
wanted our peer researchers who are in
the field doing the research
to even talk about their experiences as
peer researchers let alone findings
because they viewed that as evidence
that they in fact owned and would be
controlling the dissemination of these
findings and
it wasn't you know
it's
it's not a
it's happened more than once so it's it
is a issue and we have had conversations
with with many partners about this and
this is impossible i mean it's
completely disempowering to
to not
i mean it's it's transformative for peer
researchers to do this work in their
communities to be part of thinking about
issues
and ways forward and not then support
them to be part of that way forward and
and talking about this
especially as that is our expectation
that that's a critical piece of the
research so this is just a little um
you know our
we use the
that one
um you know we strive to ground our
model and anti-oppression principles
it's transformative from the beginning
it's i mean it was hugely transformative
for us as an organization let alone
uh you know
anything else
so we strive to
ground our model in anti-oppression
principles and
practices and
and it is very very messy even our
research coordinators get confused
sometimes as to what their role is and
we've had a lot of long conversations in
the community you know are they
community workers are they advocates for
community issues are they responsible
for data quality and research rigor
it's it is uh a complex but at the
center um
you know it are the communities and the
individuals that we work with
um
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
the
the
participatory
system change piece of the equation now
um
does research evidence really matter
yes but not so much i mean when you
start trying to do systems change work
it's another world all together and
you're
there are so many other factors and
we truly do
believe that research only matters if it
is actionable actionable but it is
easier said than done
so you know we complain about
community-based re the research piece
not being well funded well nobody funds
the participatory action so we're very
skilled at burying
and disguising
uh participatory based advocacy systems
change work into
you know a weekly drop-in free lunch for
community members or a um
you know community meetings with
stakeholders so
that's a constant sort of challenge
the environment in the public policy
space is not really receptive to
receiving input i mean better now than
it was just
a few months and weeks ago at all levels
of government
um but still it's not it's it's not uh
and and there's a huge time timing
disconnect uh you know i've talked with
people i know who work in policy roles
in government who say by the time
we put something out there as a policy
issue we want to discuss and get input
we're actually down that road we've
actually
started making decisions and mapping
pathways so it's like how and where do
you insert yourself uh
it's a huge disconnect and that's why
it's critical to partner with with
advocacy agencies that are ramped up all
the time
they might not be research agencies but
their advocacy agencies so i mean in
terms of partners
this is uh
this is a yagandra slide this was a
model developed in thailand that's used
for health change policy around the
world
and it is highly relevant that's why i
am sharing it with you today you have to
generate relevant research knowledge in
conjunction with the social movement or
social learning which includes public
knowledge and attitudes and you have to
ensure that the you have to ensure
engagement of political decision makers
including law lawmakers and the legal
system so
so it's you know moving forward on three
funds and they have to be integrated and
interconnected so you already have to be
thinking about this
as you're
just even starting research
so i just want to talk about a couple of
case examples really briefly so
um a key focus for us has been the
impact on health of vulnerable people
of precarious employment we started this
work well over 10 years ago and we're
not the only ones i mean there's some
other reports here it's uh
you know i would say precarious
employment seems to be defining
characteristic of the changing world of
work and the reality of this generation
interestingly when we started doing
community development work in a high
need neighborhood years before starting
to work on our
working rough living poor project which
was a multi-year
undertaking that actually there were
many sort of different
products
we thought we were going in to talk
about poverty we started doing focus
groups and talking about poverty and the
impact of poverty and it was community
members and youth in particular who said
it's not poverty we don't want to talk
about poverty we want to talk about
employment the the the way that our
parents are working that is impacting
our lives and running around from all of
these different jobs and they're never
home but we never have money and and
it's so unstable and it's horrible and
they talked about started talking about
the impact of that in their communities
and their lives and i mean it was
you know that
put us on a path
in terms of working with the community
one of the outcomes of this research so
i mean we we did the working poor
working rough living poor then we did
where are the good jobs which is a case
studies 10 case studies coming out of
that report and then we were part of
the cura with the um
are
like wonder women and goddesses and
robots
uh which was again a more focused case
study looking at the impact on immigrant
women of precarious employment so
um
we launched you know with so much of
this evidence and other evidence we
launched our call to good
our call to action on good jobs and
we've tried to identify what are steps
towards good jobs and have identified
this broadly we've established community
works group that undertakes actions
based on our knowledge of issues and
we've done a lot of education work with
health promoters in the health care
system
to work with them around how do they use
this evidence in a more direct way
and we feel these strategies are very
actionable you know we've got five you
know take them home think about it what
can you do in your organization there's
a lot of initiatives here the whole
decent work initiative too and
i mean we ourselves are complicit in the
whole issue of
bad jobs we need to we need to start at
home
and it's interesting
um you know access alliance our board of
directors you know we committed to 14
minimum pay for all of our roles last
year when we were working on the
minimum wage campaign
so um
and i get calls from colleagues saying
what are you doing my staff are flipping
me this poster you're they're giving me
a hard time i'm like okay
different
do something about it what could i so i
mean we've done vid uh photovoice photo
voice projects video op-ed pieces
knowledge translation is is a key piece
just talking about gray literature we
did a community health assessment report
for one of our sites
where we we take a look at what data do
we have but also what data exists out
there through other reports we pulled it
together and this was working with a
community group that you know led the
review of data and the prioritization
you know we use
matrixes you know what's what this
community think is most serious
and most impactful and then we try then
we take that directly into our program
planning and we uh
link all of these items with initiatives
that either we're trying to lead or
leading with community groups or we
bring this to community tables
so just to wrap up
you know we
this is the action piece we do have to
move forward as i said there is positive
change we have so many stakeholders in
health that are really stepping up you
know canadian doctors for refugee health
for example and
um
really doing amazing work which helps
our
systems change
so
some of our learnings is we have to use
evidence as a strategic catalyst it is
all about strategy if you don't have
strategy
there's no point the partnership piece
and a movement
a movement is critical and there are so
many important partners
that are ready and willing
mobilizing champions you talked about
that that is critical you know not only
sector champions but champions in
community
old school street rallies still are very
important i have i lost so much
patience with i went to so many rallies
but there's been like a resurgence of
rallies in the last while and you know
they get attention
um
you know ride that hyper
hyperinformation highway and rock it you
got a blog post you got a tweet you got
a facebook
we have to use what tools are available
to us money really does matter not just
from a funding perspective but there is
such interest in this return on
investment
again which i hated
but the the whole kind of return on
investment argument is a compelling
argument especially in terms of some of
the tables where we're trying to do this
systems change work creativity juice it
up i always remember dina lad when she
was doing the 14 an hour wage campaign
she talked about you know it's been the
minimum wage has been frozen at
11 for how many years and she would
bring 11 frozen into a block of ice to
meetings
which i thought was like wow and she
does things like that all the time very
creative like really making a visual
visible point and be solutions driven
you have to be able to talk about the
exact solutions that you that you that
community wants to see and that your
you're driving towards and uh be the
change you want to see and uh
so
and be passionate be the change you want
to see i mean i'm fortunate every day i
get up and
have an opportunity to go to work and
try to be that change
thank you very much
okay on time too yeah we're all doing
good eh yeah you did great and we'll
we'll open it up to a couple questions
thank you okay i love juice it up um and
and i we're we're gonna oh you know
we're gonna take a few minutes now for
questions but there were so many things
i think you packed into their cracked
open i just want to flag a few that i
hope will kind of come back to
either now or later you know i think um
there was this
discussion point about undoing the
hierarchical view qualitative versus
quantitative data i assume that really
resonates with people in the room so
let's make sure that comes out in the
discussion or in the groups
this knowledge translation question
about
only valuable if it's shared and used
i think there's a lot of richness in a
conversation about that and where it's
happening what's stopping some of this
rich data from being used the
underfunding of community organizations
to actually do this work the money
really really really matters um and then
these various dimensions of messiness
that you talked about um to use your
term around the ownership of the data
the
the researcher versus advocate tension
there were a number of different
dimensions i think that we could call
just some of the complexity and
messiness of this kind of work and this
kind of work together so thank you for
cracking so many things open that i hope
we can revisit but for um let's take a
couple of minutes um to just take any
questions top of mind that people have
um
where is the mic i got it here okay
perfectly great
so
a big fan of your work and i was
wondering
do you have any peers like has anyone
followed in your footsteps when you
created the first research department
within a chc
um i don't i'm not sure i'm not sure
that many others have followed that and
that must have been brave and
resourceful to start that and to build
that with the same funding that
everybody else gets um
are you
are you mentoring any others who are
following in your footsteps
well that's a good question um
there are a few years and you know
everything has ups and downs a few years
ago there was a community-based research
network
that was pulling together a lot of
people that were engaged and they were
meeting but they lost some steam and i
don't i think it's mostly and we were
very active for a period of time in
driving that there are community health
centers and other organizations that do
research
um but sometimes it's more one-off or
it's a piece of work
and
you know
uh or for example there's a sister
community health center that they do
research but they don't they work with
researchers who come in and so they
still drive a lot of it so um
it's a challenge we want to actually get
back to that we're looking at trying to
create a sort of a research advisory
table and for sure in this targets
driven world
uh some you know sometimes we have to
try to figure out how to put some you
know because those staff their the
funding is it's they're unit producing
positions that's what they're called
right unit producing positions
so we sometimes need to think about what
are those units we're reporting on
what
i think um
this this note about it being kind of
courageous and bold i think is important
one um
what did it actually take what was the
impetus for you just making that
decision to have that in-house research
capacity well i think it was because we
were so focused on immigrant and
refugees and
you know within health commitment
evidence-based there just was no
evidence and we were
being so offended
cons constantly by these calls for can
you put us in touch with this community
that uh you know the combination of
uh and then we needed questions answered
and there was no information
okay
so we're going to shift this to maureen
and is it just next in line here
right
getting cred that's your shirt excel did
you walk away with something um do you
want to just use this or did you say the
lab oh you got your okay
i'm always quick to accuse excel
thanks for including west neighborhood
house in this discussion
um west neighborhood house formerly
known as saint christopher house is a
multi-service neighborhood center proud
member of toronto neighborhood centers
and the canadian association of
neighborhood services and even the
international federation of settlements
um and uh we our mission is to enable
people to gain greater control of their
lives and over their communities and
more recently our mission statement
still stands but
robin's been helping us with our theory
of change so we're also committing to
a shorter version which is
personal change and social change work
together
i'd like to
start with just a bit of an overview but
mostly disclaimers i'm not going to be
using lots of
case studies
but i did want to
make sure folks knew that any of my
negative references today aren't
referring to the wonderful partnership
we had that we're probably most well
known for
with david hilchansky and the team at
the city center on neighborhood change
and that resulted in the three cities uh
report that's been on the globe and star
front pages many times so that was a
wonderful community academic partnership
and so we've learned many lessons out of
that but we've also had other
experiences and have witnessed other
experiences that have been less than
great
between academics and community working
together so my
effort today is to try to improve the
impact of our work
together
we both i think academics and community
care about the communities we're looking
at and so we're we we have a good
starting point already
i think there's a perceived problem that
we're not seen to be very credible
and i think there's some notable
exceptions but many um of the audiences
that we think are important
um
maybe don't think we're very credible
um and i feel like we're challenged a
lot about our credibility
west neighborhood house is not a
research shop we're more like
as excel referred to we work with
academics we work with researchers on
project specific pieces but we are very
committed to public policy and that's
that's what's driving our work is public
policy change
so because we get
challenged about credibility we feel we
need to be very critical and
self-critical we absolutely have a role
in the problem um while appreciating
that there are good reasons why where
our credibility falls down sometimes
and again i really do want to emphasize
uh we were very fortunate to be working
with a wonderful team at the city's
center
and
learned some good things there
so i think we've talked kim's talked
about it excel's talked about it there
is an assumption that because academics
want to work with community and
community wants to work with academics
that we have an interest in changing
public policy i was trying to think of
examples of where that might not be true
and i'm sure there might be some but
generally i think we're largely trying
to do this work to influence the
conditions
for less advantaged people and that
would
lead you to i think improving public
policy pretty quickly
so what do academics contribute to
credibility
uh in terms of public policy development
one is the rigorous methodologies and i
think excel we might have some room here
for some debate about the use of gray
evidence or gray research
and rigor but it is a problem in our
credibility when we do use gray
research
the rigor is often seen to be lacking in
community and academic partnerships um
there's my colleague diane from
woodgreen i think is one of the most
vocal critics and i completely share her
concern about just because it's in the
community doesn't mean that it needs to
be less than fully rigorous
so rigor is really important
academics have an advantage on us in the
community because we're seen to
sometimes be feathering our own nest as
community organizations talking about
the need of the community uh over and
over again academics don't have that
there are jobs uh secure and so
that sense of some objectivity and
distance is a helpful thing in terms of
credibility
and another big uh big piece is
especially when you don't have
researchers on staff is academics are up
to date in knowledge however there is a
a problem around silos and so come to
that in a minute
as a problem area
what community organizations do in terms
of contributing to credibility is i
think we bring a lot of relevancy to the
table i think we can help identify
issues that are meaningful to the
community and that's not only helpful
for the community but it's helpful to
engage the political
representatives very early on in
something if it's meaningful to the
community you can bet it's meaningful to
a political
representative
so one of the challenges we sometimes
get is who cares who cares about this
work well being relevant and to the
community
really does help answer that question
appropriate solutions i think that
community organizations are good often
as a screen for what's appropriate um
not not to be completely controlling a
community's response to things but
sometimes we can head off some damage
by well-intended
research findings that might be
translated into a public policy that
actually has some negative implications
so
just a little bit more of the cumulative
lived experience that we've seen at the
front line as witnesses can help
make sure that there's appropriateness
and nuance in
in using research
accessibility is a third area
and this is a very large
part of public policy development is
making sure the language is clear and
accessible
civil servants and politicians are smart
enough but they don't particularly care
for some of the language that academics
use and our community certainly is often
feeling lost and left behind with
academic reports so this is the
uh the challenge we get is often what
the heck are you talking about um so
accessible language is is very very
important for that
now hillary did something tricky with me
here oh there he is
the
credibility problems and i'm trying to
pick on both community organizations and
academics equally but if you feel i'm
being unfair please feel free to jump at
me but academics
i've talked with some academics about
some of the reluctance we see for them
to get engaged in public policy they'll
do the research but they don't really
see their roles going beyond that so
i've i've really been asked asking them
about that and it's very clear
especially for younger academics early
in their career there's no incentives
for them to get involved beyond the
publishing of their of their research
they may have the best of intentions but
they actually do need to move on to the
next project and publish some more so
that's a built-in structural problem in
academia that i think is is a problem we
do know there's some incentives and
things like the cfar fellowships and
others are a really good way to round
that picture out a bit but i think we
need to see a lot more incentives built
in for for academics to to be involved
in in the result moving the results of
their research into public policy change
um
i i have a pretty big rant about
ideology
in community and academic research i'm
going to try to keep that lid down
but
there's really
yeah give me a drink
the
you know we've been shot down so many
times uh
when we're meeting with political
representatives or civil servants if
anybody mentions the word neoliberal
agenda
now there is a very valid critique about
the neoliberal agenda but honestly it is
not something that the public really
likes to hear about they think it's code
for something else um certainly
politicians and civil servants think
that that is a big big red flag if
you're starting to use that kind of
language so again i'm not saying there
isn't huge validity in a neoliberal
critique but honestly it is something
that falls very flat when you're trying
to move public policy forward it's
something that falls very flat on
community members usually
and i think we really do need to
really watch our language on that so
neoliberal is my pet peeve
word but
there are other words and there's other
framing of of uh
research and community issues in
abstract language that that is that is
almost insulting to the intelligence of
people that it could be said actually in
much clearer language and it feels over
fancified
um
the third area is that we believe uh um
many academics aren't talking to each
other and increasingly the world i think
demands that we're multidisciplinary so
kim it sounds like your team is 30
people it sounded like across
disciplines the other issue that that we
have is um
we think that there's not a lot of
attention being given to behavioral
insights almost all community work we
assume has something to do with human
behavior and there's so many new
insights in behavioral economics or
social psychology that aren't being well
utilized in some fields so there's the a
lot of us in the community don't know
which faculty to go to to find support
or research
that would be helpful so i think there's
a big area around behavioral insights
and again it looks like cfar is is
really on top of that and i think united
way is also very on top of that we
really do need to be
getting at some of these new fields that
can help
explain
behavior can suggest ways that we can
get some behavior change
while not letting go of the structural
issues that obviously still need to be
attended to
now to pick on
yeah i was going to skip over critiquing
the community sector but i think i
better go back to that
so community organizations excel has
talked about this we really lack the
resources and core skills to produce
rigorous research ourselves with notable
exceptions like access alliance wood
green social planning toronto the united
way um there are few that that actually
do that and and they are doing it at the
cost of something else because they're
not getting funding for this generally
um it's not just the money though for
core staff to do it it's also some of
this ability to keep on top of current
research or new areas of of insight and
and that's really demanding and and
that's where uh uh i think community
organizations need to be clear about
what we don't know
um
this is sort of being funny about
community workers distrust but actually
more realistically they loathe
quantitative methodologies the use of
control groups that kind of stuff
there is a numeracy issue in the general
public to begin with and so our staff
reflect that um there there really is a
huge concern that quantitative methods
will miss nuance
however i think that at the sake of
nuance we've we've gone so far sometimes
um that that we're missing the
quantitative stuff that is possibly um
going to make the case um so this is
again this issue of which faculty or
which field of expertise do you use um
can we get some quantitative stuff and
some qualitative stuff working together
better
it's really important and it's a huge
part of the credibility problem i think
we have
and many i can many community
organizations um
i think believe that okay the report's
been published academically there we go
our you know now the world will know and
it's really not true many community
organizations think that um
that it's sufficient to just have this
research being done and that's what i
think we're really concerned about the
the drop off that happens after research
is done
there isn't a lot moving on to the
public policy development
so how do we make use of our respective
resources and speaking with some
academics about this we had a really
interesting conversation about some of
the steps for making evidence-based
public policy changes um so
my suggestion and it's very much open to
debate is identifying the issue and the
research question and the appropriate
researchers maybe is the is led by the
community organization clearly needs
academic help especially in identifying
appropriate researchers but i think but
the community organizations are the ones
who really need to drive what is
meaningful for the community to be
researched
the research i think is squarely in the
hands of academics um
if they can use
peers and community members wisely and
appropriately that's all the better but
but this seems to be of an appropriate
lead for researchers
engaging people most affected through
the whole process i think we both have
obligations for that and it means some
adjustments for academics and it means
some adjustments for community
organizations to meaningfully keep the
community engaged as they see fit uh
through these processes
and then from four on is where i think
we
we see things have dropped off and i'm
suggesting that we really need to pay
attention now from four to seven those
steps are often missing in public policy
development coming out of
community-based research or community
and academics working together on a
community issue
disseminating the research results and
doing public education the need for
clear language and design the need for
us all to be working with contracting
out if pos if necessary to someone who
can clad
um a research document so clear language
and design
is a skill in and of itself and a lot of
people don't have that skill in our
sector or in academia it's really well
worth contracting that out and doing it
in the form of a briefing note that can
be given over to civil servants and
politicians
engaging the public and champions and
and and decision makers i think
community organizations are well placed
to be the lead on that because we have
mass in terms of community members we
have some heft there that might carry
some more weight but we do need
champions and i would include academics
as champions as well there
we need help uh monitoring
implementation of any public policy
changes and celebrating appropriately
and letting people know when there are
positive changes which we almost never
do
and also re-strategizing when there's
news about setbacks in public policy
development or failures and i think
that's something that none of us are
doing enough of is monitoring public
policy implementation and we both have
an obligation to do that and then
finally evaluating the the outcomes um
over some period of time i would say and
suggest that that is an academic
responsibility with community
organizations continuing to do it as
well
so bottom line i think that maybe we
could be talking more about a different
way of working together a new kind of
partnership between academics and
community organizations with the
explicit goal of public policy change
not the explicit goal of let's just see
what's going on in the community but
it's it's it's to drive through to the
end of the process to say there should
be some changes and improvements in
public policy
um i think we all need to acknowledge we
have a shared responsibility for
credibility we need to be checks and
balances on each other there's a real i
think
mistake in many community organizations
that academics are the smart ones well
academics can be very smart academics
have education on their side but
community members there's a tremendous
amount of smarts there too and i think
that there's a
a reluctance to challenge academics
that's really ridiculous and we do have
to get a little bit more confident about
our own smarts
um and and we need to challenge each
other because ultimately we're going to
be challenged somewhere else so we
really do need to make sure we're clear
about our work where it's relevant work
the nuance is there and to respond to
what would the critics say so before we
go out with anything let's do a test of
what would other stakeholders with some
vested interest against our vision um
what would they say and and and work
through that
um and then finally i think um using um
just
continuing to commit to each other that
we'll
respect each other's complementary uh
rules and work together but also let the
academics do what they do best and let
the community do what they do best uh
all the while working together and and
in cooperation
so that's my uh
my presentation i'd be happy to take uh
any questions or challenges
all right so let's open it up i just
want to say um thank you for i think
what um is a very thoughtful and
balanced and also solutions oriented
presentation and approach i think you've
given a lot of concrete suggestions on
both how to leverage credibility better
on both sides but also some
practical
and specific ways that that academics
and community could work cool more
closely together so let's spend some
time now but also later in the smaller
groups you know digging specifically
into some of these suggestions on you
know what would it take for this
paradigm to shift what would it take to
have more wins and more concrete
examples like we're hearing of today of
these successful relationships and
partnerships um so let's open it up any
um yep please
what's your name
good morning thank you maureen this
question's from maureen and for excel
i'm mark campbell from nia center for
the arts
have in in your 10-year experience of
community research and from your
experience with saint christopher house
have there been wins in in terms of
public policy change that has been
celebrated both
with your team and on the academic side
because i know as a metric in
universities social policy change is not
necessarily at the top of the list if it
has nothing to do with uh tuition fees
and head counts and and you know funding
of students so maybe if either of you
can respond to that that would be great
we've done some public policy work um
without academics
the modernizing income security for
working age adults had very minimal
academic
presence in it but it did have some
researchers
policy analysts and there were some wins
out of that the ontario child benefit is
one of them the working income tax
benefit is another they're not perfect
solutions and we can't claim all the
credit for them but certainly we feel
the mobilizing effort that we did with
some of the research so there's a common
database that no one disputed multiple
stakeholders including very very
conservative folks as well as activists
people with lived experience agreed on
it was very powerful uh politicians in a
way couldn't say no
um so that that's concrete but it's not
that doesn't that wasn't really out of a
community uh university alliance
the neighborhood change project with
david holchanski and and
the large uh academic team there we
haven't seen obviously the kind of
changes we would like to see certainly
the public attention is on the issue of
increased income inequality and how it
plays out geographically i still don't
think that's a win i don't think we
should give up um yet on on that because
we haven't
just getting more publicity is not in in
my view a win at all but excel do you
have other examples
we take credit for a lot of things
so i mean years ago the first research
project we did which was um looking at
needs and issues related to
uh immigrants and refugees in the
shelter system
and you might remember maureen years and
years ago there was and we were we were
actually really strategic about engaging
with the city and there were what there
was at that time uh a response a funding
response related to
um making language interpretation
available to shelters which previously
hadn't been putting settlement workers
in shelters and then there were a couple
of other sort of uh less sort of
services but more policy i think there
was a change or a revision of training
for shelter workers and i mean
we were you know we did the research
work and then we were we created all of
these working groups with community
members and staff which led to all of
this but i think that's an example of
sort of a service
focus we like to think that we were the
first ones to start talking about
precarious employment and
now it's on the world's radar i think
you're right so um
yeah there has been there we wouldn't be
able to continue this work if we didn't
have some successes but we could do a
better job for sure of talking about
them and building on them
okay let's let's move to phillip and
then we'll have a few minutes before
we'll take a mid-morning break um to uh
have a few more questions
um
yeah i think mark's question is really
uh you know at the key of the matter of
like you know
when does research actually translate to
change in policy
uh and i think uh
excel said uh life is messy i would say
research is messy as well and um you
know charting how research turns into
policy changes is really
uh you know
um sometimes frustrating sometimes uh
challenging you know and i think uh
maureen had this uh or maybe music had
this a triangle
of you know you needed political support
uh you needed uh to be on the ground
floor and you needed credible research
and it it's rare for all those things to
line up it does happen and there's some
stories one example i give
as well but maybe talk later
on
application assistance to fill out for
financial aid some of the work that
i and
others have been doing on trying to
simplify the process of getting through
the application post-secondary uh seems
to have attracted um you know a lot of
attention and interest in you know
simplifying or making the transition to
post-secondary easier um but there are
other examples um but they're they're
not as many as as we'd like
okay so i i think i've got five minutes
or less
so i'm gonna uh this is great thank you
for having me and and i'm gonna echo a
lot of points um that maureen made maybe
a bit more on the academic side
uh
and so i i thought i'd give you a little
bit of a case study
uh in trying to work with uh pathways to
education to try to do some uh research
many of you know uh that this
organization was a grassroots
organization that started in uh well the
program was implemented in 2001
uh at regent park which is not too far
from here it's the largest housing
project in in the country
and uh the purpose was to try to break
the cycle of poverty and was motivated
by uh
um it was started at the community
health organization
they managed to raise some money from
the trillium foundation
and
had the luxury to really think about
introducing a very integrated
complete expensive program
to try to see if they could help
disadvantaged youth
especially through high school so very
briefly the program um
is is starts for
people entering grade nine and they get
a very integrated set of programs anyone
who lives in regent park uh and and now
other projects entering grade nine is
eligible for the program it's voluntary
they have to sign a forum to commit to
the program the parents sign a form as
well and then if they do that they get
assigned a
student support
worker that meets with them about every
two weeks
and
helps guide them throughout their high
school
time in high school and then they also
get a tutoring up to four nights a week
and tutoring is supposed to be mandatory
up to two times a week on top of that
there's a whole
set of social support there's
monthly or bi-monthly group activities
including issues around stress
management or just going to a sporting
event and then there's financial support
in the terms of free public
transportation and also a post-secondary
scholarship that's four thousand so it's
very integrated approach uh you probably
know about pathways because of this
report that came out in 2007 by the
boston consulting group and at the very
bottom here they have um uh that the
before pathways uh from regent park the
dropout rate was 56 percent high school
dropout rate after pathways it was 10
percent uh for 80 percent reduction in
you know david pico who uh had the study
was um
on the consulting firm he was also on
the pathways board of directors he said
uh you know this is the highest rate of
turn that we've ever seen now
uh
this
this uh change is is off the charts and
it's uh
um
you know we don't see these kind of
impacts uh in education programs
almost anywhere and so to kind of
have that kind of impact and say this is
what pathway is doing
uh it it certainly um
asks for
um
further research so anyone seeing this
you know doing research in education
gets uh really excited but also you know
naturally skeptical wanting to uh kind
of understand
whether this is real if it is real how
is it happening and so um
pathways got a lot of attention from
this and they managed to you know expand
it and and
go national from it um but it uh this
kind of program and the research
related to trying to evaluate shouldn't
stop there
um and the
uh it is worthwhile to try to have um
others try to uh
look at the program from a different
perspective
maybe a different methodology
um and and it is healthy to have uh
a dialogue and discussion on
whether these this is the truth
uh and and i think that's where
academics can uh come and help
um
but also
there's some
um
tension that sometimes comes with that
because from the organization's point of
view
uh this result is you know
um
is is
enough to um you know is is in the
direction that they want to see
um
this is a slide is similar to
uh marines in terms of like well what's
in it for organizations to kind of have
more academics play um you know
a role in trying to evaluate the program
um
i think she said there's some incentive
there seems to be some impression that
if the research is only done internally
there's uh
feathering one's own nest right
uh
and
uh one advantage if um in you know for
for to have
additional multiple investigations of
the program is you can have arms length
interest for looking at it this brings
credibility
also brings alternative uh perspectives
and we're cheap uh too sometimes we're
more interested in you know we're happy
to kind of participate and look at it
for the sake of science um and
and
you know you know we don't you know
don't have to pay us consulting fees
um
sometimes we have uh you know
emphasis on causal inference trying to
understand
um what is the
uh
what is the counterfactual what's the
comparison group trying to understand
and evaluate the program
and
we might be able to have um bring more
time to the investigation often the
organizations themselves are just are
very busy operating the program and the
capacity to do detailed research is
limited so we can do that and the last
one i don't know if you guys have seen
down here is just more and more funders
want it funders want to see sort of some
external type of evaluation
um and uh
and and so that's another reason of
course the other reason not to want this
is that well
we might find results that uh you know
disappoint the organization
and uh there's very little
often incentive for an organization to
welcome
researchers in when they have you know
a strong support for the program already
and
also you know it's important as an
academic to be able to
state what you think the conclusions of
your own research are and it's important
to have a dialogue with the organization
prior you know to talking about the
research
but um you know
no academic wants to be in this
situation to have um
you know a filter from the organization
what you're able to say
and so
it's important
to have
a non-filtered
presentation results that can also stand
up to scrutiny and sometimes the
organizations are nervous about that
sometimes
in order to do the research
the operations may not may actually need
to be changed or flexible in order to
accommodate evaluation
um and this is often easier said than
done you know there's different
methodologies
um
it was discussed earlier that sometimes
there's a methodology hierarchy
and that exists for a reason
you know often
if you're able to set up a randomized
controlled trial you have a credible
comparison group more credible than
anything else you can produce and at
least on an aggregate level
in in in very specific contexts you're
able to tell what would have happened in
the absence of
treatment or an accident program
sometimes these things can be set up
easier than others
um and and sometimes they're not easily
set up but
trying to accommodate
uh
the research to set up a comparison
group is
extremely useful and we learn a lot from
it but often uh it might require uh
change we still need the qualitative
research as well but to really
understand
um
you know the bigger picture uh
it it very helps a lot to
have a credible comparison group
um one small example is the big brothers
big sisters study that they had a long
lineup but people wanted to be a big
brother and big sister and they took
advantage of that lineup and then rather
than going in order they took a series
of people and they said would you be
okay with uh
selecting at random from the lineup who
gets a bigger sister big brother
quicker and from that they were able to
assess um
program so in the pathways example it
took me three years to sort of establish
the relationship to kind of say i didn't
have an ideology i just i really wanted
to know whether this was real and and
wanted to see whether this program was
going and
you know it took a long time because
there was reluctance and concern you
almost have nowhere to go but down in
terms of once you have a 56 to 10
percent uh result and you know to be
honest it helped that most of my
analysis it took a while to realize this
could come from data from outside
pathways um and i think from that and
also just a lot of goodwill and sitting
down with them uh you know it
establishes relationships so uh very
quickly
um
you know it actually does turn out that
uh pathways has a very high
participation rate so within two years
of the program these red bars show that
in regent park participation goes up
above 80 percent and and
of all the people who could be
participating in pathways you've got you
know 85 90 percent of people
volunteering for the program which is
very high take up and the other lines
are for the other sites uh lawrence
heights and um
and rexdale that were introduced in 2007
also almost immediately participation is
really high uh and so the way that this
study was set up you know we can't
randomize reason pathways but uh what we
have is people from other housing
projects and this shows the um the
enrollment rate and post-secondary after
five years since starting grade nine
and uh you sh i show you uh for those
who start in grade nine starting in 2000
or 2001 all the way up to 2009 what the
post-second enrollment rates are
um over over time so you see them edging
up around 30 and so the orange dot is
what it was for regent park for 2000
before pathways was introduced and so
without the absence of the program the
comparison group is to sort of follow
this line and say that's probably what
would have happened or that's our best
guess what would happen so when you
actually go to the data look at regent
park you actually do see a fairly
substantial rise in
post-second enrollment in fact if you
normalize this if you kind of put these
back together
uh the gap that opens up
uh almost exactly the time that pathway
was introduced was a very large rise
um and and so it turns out with with the
data that i was obtained at my best
guess of this impact for regent park was
almost a 19 percentage point increase in
post-secondary which is also off the
charts was very encouraging so when you
go look at the other sites that were
introduced in 2007 instead of this 19
percentage point you have a much lower
estimated impact a 3.5 percentage point
increase in um
enrollment although if you focus on just
college you get a 6.5 percentage point
increase in community college enrollment
which is still generally impressive um
but if you you know you go back and you
report these results to pathways and and
others generally the reaction is mixed
there's sort of some disappointment that
i wasn't able to show the 56 percent you
know this is this giant um increase
uh but from that work uh there's ongoing
um qualitative work to try to understand
what's going the mechanisms that's going
on there and um
uh that and that's i'm not uh and so
i've had to team up with some people
doing qualitative work uh to try to get
down and i have to say also this
from an academic to really get on the
ground floor to work with these people
on sites it is a pleasure it is because
you get some idea of all the effort and
and um the messiness going on the ground
floor that needs to be appreciated that
uh you don't when you're doing uh you
know when you're just showing those
figures so i think the combination of
the research is important and from that
you learn stuff like
um the attendance for the tutoring and
and uh meeting the coaches is actually
not that high or not as high as they
would say it is uh from the you know the
rules of the program so one of the
things that we're trying to explore now
is to try to ways find what find ways to
increase attendance to see within the
program whether that actually would make
it improve so it's not just about the
evaluation of the program as a whole but
how things could be improved internally
so one thing is we're looking at is
texting um to provide more salient
reminders sending messages on the day
that tutoring could be occurring
to encourage participation and a you
know a big advantage of the texting is
that
it's cheap and you can randomize who you
text to and so we have a comparison
group to explore how participation
changes uh and whether through in
increased particip whether this uh
mechanism can uh increase participation
get more people to the tutoring and and
the coaching
so um i know i'm out of time so let me
just kind of summarize it at um
uh
there is um
you know there's a need to
uh work together it often requires um
sort of respectful
um open-minded relations and so as an
academic you have to realize that uh
you know you can't just
trounce in and say you're doing it all
wrong you have to do it you have to
really understand where they're coming
from
uh but also you know be really open
um minded and also encourage scrutiny
scrutiny is healthy
um trying to understand the truth what
works to make things better because we
are you know related and trying to
um improve well-being especially for uh
some of these disadvantaged families and
um
i think there's lots of room to try to
do that together
okay thanks
all right
um so open it up to a few questions but
i i first i want to say that was
fascinating um and i really want to
acknowledge you
for
sticking with it for three years
and generating that enough goodwill
because i i can imagine how important
that was to be able to
offer what sounds like has been very
useful data for program improvement and
deepening and enhancing the outcomes
that they're able to generate and i'm
sure that wasn't easy um and lots of i
think richness in this question and i
think as you framed it about accepting
negative data um being willing to sort
of embrace potentially things that
aren't working in the spirit of being
able to make sure you're allocating
those resources in a way that could have
more impact um and this idea of ongoing
research and and implementing diverse
methodologies i think has um i think a
lot of a lot of important value um so
just to pull out a few things let me
turn it over to you who's got um any
questions for phillip
yeah
okay any any new hands we'll come there
okay go ahead what's what's your name
hi i'm bill with st stevens community
house i'm doing some youth research as
well right now so i'm very interested in
your your thoughts about text messaging
and i know you were hurting at the end
like text messaging is a good way to
send information to youth are you
finding it a good way to collect
information from youth
um
there are there are different
possibilities with text you know maureen
brought up behavioral insights there's a
lot of
it was great to hear that people are
thinking about you know behavioral
economics on this stuff there's a lot of
um interesting
uh theories behind why texting both
pushing out messages and kind of
receiving messages uh might be very
helpful pushing out is the issues around
you know just
providing salient reminders at the time
that you might take action often leads
to a higher likelihood of actually doing
that action but receiving messages also
really opens up a line of communication
that we've never really had before it's
a really cheap way
of
of having
students or
individuals feel that they can reach out
with someone at any time during the day
uh at
a time when something pops up in their
head where they don't have to sort of
then uh set up a schedule or meeting and
so one project to have right now is uh
with first year undergraduates where
when we say send messages
uh they can respond to us and uh often
the message themselves when you send
something is a reminder that they can
send a message back and that's when we
get the most uh communication
and um you know this research is ongoing
but the the sense is that the
um
the the the students who do respond
really appreciate the line of
communication of being able to talk to
um you know a faculty member at nine
o'clock at night uh it goes to me
sometimes
uh or or
um you know a graduate student or
someone some you know that that there
doesn't need to be a pause between the
idea that some comes ahead and a need to
communicate so i think texting is a new
technology that we're only now becoming
aware that it might be
an effective
addition
to some of the programs the way that
we're implementing the programs
thanks for that question yeah thank you
i i wanted to get um just more from you
you said at the beginning
you academics are great partners
sometimes because you're committed to
the work you have the skills to do the
work and you're cheap
so i wanted to explore that a little bit
more
for lots of different reasons
but one of them you know you're cheap
sometimes but not always when we have
tenders going out for different research
projects for example if we get bids from
academic teams we often have to they
they have to submit their bids with
these large
management fees from the institutions
but what does that what are the
different options for relationships for
community organizations with academics
to do the work the kind of work you're
doing on program improvement the kind of
work we might need on other kinds of
research that we might want to be doing
and how do we go how do we all get to
know about the different routes into
building those relationships and taking
advantage of uh the cheapness sometimes
yeah sure that's a good question i mean
the pathways is an example where
uh you know
this project was done on on no money uh
you know that the money that for doing
the qualitative study is picking up um
but
the
the data was made available apart from
pathways apart from ptsb for free
uh and you know the interest in in sort
of a young academic wanting to
understand
uh
a project that seemed quite attractive
the interest or incentive
for me was to
understand this program a little bit
better and have the opportunity to share
results the research so
um you know often
the chance to publish
but publish also means disseminate and
discuss and and share ideas the chance
to do that is is often more valuable
than than you know um being paid
sometimes the research involves uh you
know hiring research assistants and
other things but uh that's part of what
we do and we raise money for that so um
i've often thought that
sometimes when these calls for proposals
for research it you know it's possible
to direct
attention or try to find academics who
are genuinely interested in this area
that might be interested in
um you know working with data sets that
they would not have normally accessed
through through these kind of partners
and um
and and be interested the one thing i
would say is as long it it helps a lot
if there's a long time uh period between
um you know putting together a proposal
so often you will get these um
requests saying there's a lot of money
available if you submit a proposal in
two weeks and it's just not enough time
to drop everything and kind of really
think about that so maybe there's a
trade-off but my suspicion is that there
is more possibilities in
in
bringing on economics that are willing
uh or more interest in the research than
uh you know than getting paid
uh to
um
as long as they had more you know space
to fit it in yeah and i think there's
reminds me of something else obviously
but earlier there's some mutuality in
that as well we need the time to build
the relationships between the academic
and the community organization and
partners
but it's similar we often get requests
and i know many of the agencies get
requests to be part of different shirk
or other other tri-council grant
applications
uh three days before the application is
due
and that to me is kind of the similar
the other side of that too and how we
how we better build some understanding
on the need for having lead up time and
time to build relationships to learn to
work together and take advantage of both
the opportunities that we offer each
other so i really appreciate your
comments phil
hi i'm diane dyson from wood green
and really followed your research a long
time so really glad to hear you speak to
this and and you're speaking about
pathways to education which is one of my
long-time areas of interest as well as
looking like you um how how do we
improve the outcomes for
young people
in education um and so i have all sorts
of methodological questions that i
wanted to sort of get into with you but
i think for the use of the room what
might be more interesting is that one of
the shifts that happened in pathways
education is after it moved out of
regent park and moved into other
neighborhoods and across canada
it it was able to do that because it had
the external
um
validity of a boston consulting
evaluation that said this is the return
on dollar with something like 14 or 18
dollars in quite an incredible number um
when you look at other srois and so they
were able to do that and then um when
they moved into the other places you've
known you've noted and shown us today
that their outcomes were not as good i'm
wondering if that was then perhaps the
burden is on us as as community groups
should that happen to us that we need to
make sure that we've got the inside the
program evaluation knowing well enough
so we know whether text messages work
whether we know whether the counseling
or the attendance work those sorts of
things that that we have to make sure
that we've paid enough um attention to
the internal processes so that there's
some fidelity when we go to other when
we try to scale up our our programs
yeah it's a um it's a really good point
it's hard to
um
scale up and replicate what seems to be
working there's a little bit of um
uh
sort of a
scala bias where you you find a study
that or you know some some initial
program looks like it's working
amazingly well
and then uh you know there could be a
lot of luck involved in that or a
particular champion behind the program
that's really hard to pinpoint or get a
finger on what's driving that and so
when you expand it um it is uh
you know more often than not that
when you when you look at the um
the evaluation of the expansion projects
they're not as um you know as striking
but i do think
you know an another reason could be that
the initial results were not as uh
um
you know there's some noise around your
estimates on the impact of the program
maybe it wasn't as effective to begin
with but i was thinking you know it is
worth noting that pathways
um you know is a promising program it
looks like it has a lot of ingredients
and would not have expanded were it not
for that study right and it were it not
for them you know uh problems aside
uh problem the program would not have
you know probably taken up beyond regent
park if it was just some academic coming
up with a published academic paper with
it with just my report i doubt it would
have the same kind of impact so it is
sort of important that that they had
that uh
report that came out at the same time
but i agree with you that that
trying to understand the mechanisms
both at regent park and the expansion
sites to be open to constant change and
tweaking uh is is healthy to constantly
try to improve on it
yeah great great point
um
and it sounds like a one around scaling
in general around this this tension
between fidelity to a model versus
adaptation to a new context or
environment that that i think was in
pathways case sounds like an important
uh consideration um
okay
we we're gonna take a break right about
now um
and i've sure changed some of the
questions at this point let's let's open
it up to if we have any last question
did you have one okay if we have any
last question and then we'll break a
move to the um to the breakouts any
final yeah please
well i i don't really have a question
but i wanted to
to say that
sitting as the uh
in a community-based organization and
admire the fact that
other organizations have been able to
create opportunities to do research
one of the things that i find really
difficult about it is that we
kind of have to piggyback on existing
projects because there are no resources
so when you talk about
engagement and you were talking before
about engaging with the academics and
the community members before and so on
i'm sitting here thinking okay
when am i going to get the time
and who in my organization can i say
okay stop doing what you're doing the
thing you were talking about units and
you know we have numbers to meet we have
those kinds of things to me
that's right and and so the reality of
of being able to do this
uh is uh very very difficult
from where we sit now i think it's
really important because the credibility
factor is not only in the credibility of
the research and the outcomes but it is
really being able to demonstrate as
community organizations that we are
doing something that is impactful that
is meaningful that is
important and that is based on evidence
and based on you know and we have very
good uh support from from people in the
academic community
wherever we we need that credibility on
our level to keep doing our work so it's
uh it's just striking me as a whole
other like we could open the warden
woods research arm
in order to support all of the the
issues and types of things that we're
dealing with as a multi-service
organization so it's necessary
uh
we're trying
but i'm just overwhelmed with how we're
gonna do it off the side of our desks
with everything else
lots of nodding heads there were lots of
nodding heads to that comment yes yes
and the good news is is we have some
funders in the room to hear that um but
it's it sounds like it's a bigger
problem question yeah you want to
respond to that phil just just one
thought because like as as a quick and
dirty uh
way to maybe get up and running i mean
there might there are lots of better
ways to do this but um just letting
um
uh
researchers at universities in uh
interested in community work or
qualitative work um that have done
you know have similar interests letting
them know that you're interested in
having
um
you know your your organization your
program evaluated or looked at
might spark interest
in in them getting involved uh without
taking up a lot of your time like just
being saying i'm
open to you coming in and looking at our
data and and giving you access to
speaking with people that's often really
attractive for
um
you know especially young academics
looking for new ideas and topics that
that would not otherwise be available to
them so that might be a quick thing to
do
um okay well let's do let's do one last
one and uh we'll still give you your
break and we'll just have a little less
time for discussion at the tail end yeah
uh thanks john kerry uh settlement
assistant family support services um but
i'm going to talk mostly on my child
development years child development
institute um
i think the first question i'm looking
for answers right now is why do we want
to do the research
because i've heard many different
reasons i think we owe it to our clients
to show that what we're doing is
effective second thing is
if we incorporate the research into what
we're already doing helps
uh deal with the issue of adding on to
so somehow it's finding that partnership
to do that and we're starting to get
involved in a study with violence
against women and it just happens to
stars a line i know what you want to
call it but
there's someone that came to us and said
we're interested in exploring this issue
and we said well we have the women that
can answer some of your questions to
start on a qualitative note so if it's
incorporated to something that you're
already doing i would see that it's a
lot easier process rather than trying to
make it work
thanks
great okay i think both both really
important points and the why question um
i do encourage you in your groups to
spend some time talking about because i
think
we've heard that there's different why's
for the researchers for the
organizations for funders how how can
you increasingly generate that kind of
alignment around the whys
which sounds like is where some of the
the real
value is going to come or at least um at
least possibility um okay so i've got
some instructions for the breakouts you
have from what i understand on the backs
of your name tags numbers
um
there are i think gonna be six breakout
groups
the
breakout groups 2 3 and 4
will be in the legacy room and we'll
have people helping to direct you but
it's out the doors to the right
right again
the other breakout groups um hillary are
going to be
um there's one group in here and then
three groups ouch directly in front so
what number's in here number one is here
okay um number let me do the math
five six seven are right out front okay
so there's three rooms like across from
where you got your coffee and and bagels
this morning those are three and then uh
two three and four around the corner um
we're we've got um you've been assigned
to groups so that we could have a mix of
researchers in the groups and community
organizations some of the funders in the
room um so it should i think inform a
dynamic discussion
and we've you're going to have sticky
notes and rather than doing kind of
report backs what i'm going to encourage
you to do is capture some of the key
points that come out of your discussion
on the blue sticky notes that you have
and and they kind of cluster around a
few themes
one around sort of general lessons
learned one around some of the
drivers of success around collaborations
and some of the ways and we've heard
you ideally talk about
what's standing in the way but what are
some of the opportunities for deeper
collaborations
and then specifically around
concrete examples of partnerships you've
been involved with what have been some
of the drivers of success so your each
group will have a lead who have a bunch
of prompting questions but i'll ask you
to kind of cluster around those themes
bring back the stickies and then with
whatever time that remains we'll come
back to a large group discussion
great so why don't we break if you could
kind of keep it to about you know seven
minutes quick bio break and grab a
coffee or whatever ten after meet in
your breakout rooms
thanks
you know if i had time to volunteer
there
yeah